hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday in his the
Warriors Den livestream recap day and
there was a lot of info on Season 5 tons
of new info we've never heard about
stuff what steel changes max level
increased new gear all information about
the reworks tons of map changes so let's
get right into that so to start off I'm
sorry if there's any repeat gameplay my
Elgato for some reason won't record so
I'm trying to fix that it should be
fixed soon so I do apologize for that
but anyway they're also trying to deal
with afk players in for honor and
they're doing that by getting data and
they're gonna be banning players that
afk farm especially in season 5 and year
2 when new players come in and try to
get on that XP farming there's gonna be
a new event game-mode this weekend it's
going to be realistic tribute that comes
with no revenge no gear stats widget and
it lasts for the entire week if you do
want to play that I've found pretty
excited for that there's also going to
be a discount on executions that are
7000 steal all 7k executions will now be
5k for a little bit so make sure to grab
those while you can now we have all the
juicy information about season 5 with a
little bit more coming next week but we
have tons to talk about so Season 5 is
going to be beginning on February 15th a
day after the game was released which
was released on February 14th of 2017
it's gonna be coming with tons new
content like Gears weapons outfits
effects as well as dedicated servers
like the weekly content it's also going
to be coming with hero reworks the first
two characters are going to be Kensi and
conqueror and they will be getting
updated move sets and animations with
Berserker Nobu Shi and Highlander
getting major balance changes later
after them next up for season 5 you can
also use Salvage to get an XP boost this
is the stuff that they were constantly
talking about of us using Salvage
instead of just keeping it forever it
only requires Salvage and you can buy
one match boost for one match so one
match boost per match it also gives your
teammate some XP but not as much as you
the price increases every time you buy a
boost so for example it could start out
at 500 and then it could go to a
thousand per boost and then eventually
reaching up to a limit where it just
kind of stops that's like that's the top
point but then eventually the price will
reset back to 500 every single day to
keep the flow going the XP boost will
show above your team in the hero select
menu all you have to do is just press
the right bumper or I believe r1 on
yes four or whatever it happens to be on
the keyboard and mouse for PC and you
can just buy it right from there if you
leave a match the XP boosts will stay on
until the match actually finishes and
yes that also counts for disconnects so
if you happen to disconnect during a
match it will not use up the XP boost it
only uses it up once the match is fully
finished next up is refined gear refined
gears gonna be this new thing for season
5 and when you reach a max level piece
of gear so level 30 no Purple's no golds
no whites it only has to be teal level
30 at this moment you can refine it for
extra stats it only counts like I said
for gear at level 30 and nothing lower
you could tell when you get refined gear
and it will give you a yellow diamond on
the top signifying that it is refined it
basically will take all three of your
stats and just give it a little bit of
an increase it all depends on what type
of armor you have or what type of weapon
it is with all the stats and whatever it
happens to be so it's a little bit
different depending on what you have but
it will give an increase on your stats
even more now not entirely sure how many
times you can refine it I believe you
can only refine it once but that's all I
know next up the max level has been
increased to rep 50 and also includes
new rewards for achieving those ranks so
it's not rep 40 anymore is now rep 50
for the faction more certain territories
are going to start having buildings on
them when you capture a territory you
can get one of three possibilities the
mill the forge and the castle which all
come with its own benefits whenever you
have the mill captured you have a ten
percent match xp for the forge you get a
7 percent loot rate and for the castle
you get 10 percent more troops on that
territory and these are all scattered
throughout the map but I believe you get
two of these two I don't know what it is
specifically whether it's two mills two
forges or one of each or whatever but
you do get a few as default to help you
with that these do stack depending on
how many territories you have so if
you're actually destroying in the
faction war you'll be getting tons of
boosts and if you're starting to lose
them you're actually going to be losing
the amount of XP you're getting so let's
say you have two mills and you're
getting a 10% match xp they one of these
let's say the samurai capture one now
they have it now you're only eating 5%
XP so you definitely want to be
participating in the faction order to
get those bonuses and make sure that the
other factions don't steal your stuff I
like this because it's giving an
incentive to actually play the faction
war and it's really nice because the
faction world is kind of
since the beginning of the game and not
many people really enjoyed playing it
next up is ranked mode you're ranked is
going to be disappearing in ranked game
modes and it will appear for the new
season just for a reset and there's also
going to be new tournament rewards and
rank Dominion is going to be
disappearing and it's going to be
replaced with rank tribute a lot of the
community actually requested that rank
tribute be a thing so they're going to
do that instead of Dominion next up is
the multiple effects clips and this is
probably my favorite thing that they're
adding meaning in it you can have
different effects on different
executions and free and combat emotes so
for example you could have the rainbow
execution or you could have the rainbow
effect for one execution and the
Hellfire on another which gives the
players tons of new customization and
diversity because with all the
executions if you add them up counting
the emotes and the idols and the
executions that's nine different effects
you can have on your character you can
be totally decked out in new effects
every single time if you really want to
and as well they're going to be changing
the community orders and it's this is a
good change and yet you now have to
participate in the community orders to
receive the rewards for it some people
would just let everyone do the work and
get the rewards as they go now you
actually have to participate it's only
one match usually if it has to do with
like completing a match all you have
what you would really have to do is just
complete one game and it still counts
but it's making those players that don't
play and are just there just to collect
it when it's over that they're not going
to get those rewards anymore and then
the last two things we have to talk
about is the arena training mode and the
new map update so let's start with the
map updates so for the new maps or for
the new map updates is going to be tower
ruin and Citadel tower ruin for tribute
and Citadel for duel for the tower ruin
change you'll now have the offerings on
different floors of the building as
opposed to spread up on the bridge and
across the map and added zip lines on
the tower to zip through the map and
place your offering in your base there's
going to be three zip lines one toward
the middle of the map and the other two
are going to be toward your base and the
opposing teams base and for Citadel the
bridge location or the dual location is
going to be changed from the bridge to
the little flat area next to it this was
to prevent a lot of legend yes there is
still alleging spot where it originally
is but they blocked off the bridge so
it's not as bad as the original so that
you actually have to fight your opponent
instead of just trying to focus on
legend them like I said the reveal of
season 5 is going to be February II
now this is not to be confused with the
actual release date the released it's
going to be February 15th but there's
going to be new info on the next
warriors then on February 8th which I
will gladly cover for you guys of course
there's going to be tons of new info
again on season five there's a lot of
stuff coming and this is going to be
really nice and then lastly then we have
the new arena training mode which is
similar to a Mortal Kombat injustice
type style where you get to change the
AI to do it whatever you want I hope you
better your play style so you can maybe
have a Sugo key only do his unblockable
so you get used to the timing have a
Raider do his unblockable to get used to
the timing and all this other type stuff
maybe a really defensive character and
it comes with more advanced tutorials
which are a lot more complex than the
current ones we have which will make
everyone a better player I also forgot
to mention there is a new content of the
week but since this video is a pretty
very long video I'm only going to show
the previews of it while I continue to
talk over it but either way thank you
guys for watching the video if you guys
did enjoy please sure to give it a like
subscribe if you into more four on our
content I cover the news the leaks the
discussion the informational sign up for
honor I cover all of that especially
with the new season 5 coming out I have
tons of videos talking about the changes
when they do release my two most recent
videos is gonna be popping up on screen
if you guys do want to check those out
thank you guys for sticking around I
hope you guys enjoyed and with that guys
have hope you have a great rest of your
day and peace out